savais-tu qu'il était possible de faire
Pat en seulement 10 coups pas de c'est
quoi pas de séquence à toi de jouer tu
peux plus rien faire tu as plus aucun
coup égal en fait tu es bloqué dans
cette situation on dit que ça fait pâte
et ça fait match nul ce sauvetage
miraculeux arrive généralement en fin de
partie quand il ne reste que peu de
pièces sur les chiquer mais là deux
joueurs se sont amusés à piéger tout le
monde de championnat d'Allemagne 1997
avec un pas totalement inattendu en
seulement 10 coups alors vous allez voir
les joueurs ont fait littéralement
n'importe quoi ils vont prendre des
pièces dans tous les sens de manière
totalement illogique et les pièces
noires se retrouvent agglutinées à
l'aile dame et on se rend compte
maintenant que tout est bloqué après
damussie c'est au nord de jouer ils
n'ont aucun coût légal il y a donc fat
une situation très cocasse qui a dû
faire rire toute la salle de